a scorching hot planet exposed to
powerful rays of the close sun
a forbidding world packed with lethal
contrasts
a lifeless sphere bearing marks of
destructive explosions
a mysterious celestial body still
harboring a great many secrets
this is mercury
the planet lying closest to the sun in
our system
let's find out more about it
[Music]
the first outer space
mercury lies relatively close to the
earth
but its exploration has always been
associated with a lot of difficulties on
account of its close proximity to the
sun it can be observed in the sky only
at the very horizon and this either
shortly before sunrise or immediately
after sunset
this is actually why ancient astronomers
took mercury for two different celestial
bodies which were given different names
only the advancement of observation
equipment enabled scientists to
gradually reveal some of this unusual
world's mysteries the accumulated data
shows mercury to be the smallest planet
in the solar system
incidentally it is even beaten by some
satellites
its radius measures
2440 kilometers which is roughly 38
that of the earth
the celestial object is remarkable for
its almost ideally round shape as the
difference between its equatorial and
polar diameters is not over one
kilometer at the same time given its
modest size mercury has a surprisingly
big mass it equals 3.33 x 10 to the
power of 23 kilograms which is
approximately five and a half percent
that of the earth
comparing mercury's parameters with
those of celestial objects close to it
in terms of their size mercury is
heavier than ganymede and titan put
together and that in spite of the fact
that both of those objects diameters are
bigger
it is probably due to the fact that
there's a massive metallic core with a
radius reaching as much as 2000
kilometers accounting for about 57
percent of the planet's volume the core
is enveloped in a 400 kilometer layer of
mantle made up of molten silicate rocks
the mantle in its turn
is covered with a hard crust as thick as
15 to 37 kilometers
as for the planet's surface it is vastly
pock marked with craters
their analysis shows the celestial body
not to have been noticeably geologically
active for the past 3.8 billion years
[Music]
bright sunlight presents difficulties in
observing mercury through a telescope
however this had been the only way of
studying the planet until as recently as
the second half of the 20th century
everything changed in 1974 when a space
probe mariner 10 reached the planet's
environs
it took pictures of 45 percent of the
celestial body's surface
and also gauged its temperature and
magnetic field in addition to that the
probes sensors registered the
exceptionally rarefied atmosphere made
up of helium and other gases
30 years later on the 3rd of august 2004
another spacecraft took off the face of
the earth
messenger it took a long 11 years to
reach its target but the little probe
did tackle all obstacles and eventually
accomplished its mission
in the period from 2011 to 2015
messenger beamed back hundreds of
thousands of images for scientists to
study including pictures of mercury's
almost entire surface
thanks to these pictures
important data was obtained on the
celestial body's inner makeup
and various features of the planet's
relief were detected
including unique ones in the solar
system
also messenger's sensors helped
suppliers with some knowledge about
solar wind and its unusual interaction
with the planet's magnetosphere
mercury follows an elongated elliptical
orbit around the sun
which takes 88 days to complete
in its perihelium the planet approaches
the sun as close as .31 astronomical
units
with the distance in the ephelium one
and a half times as big at 0.47
astronomical units
mercury's orbital resonance unique in
the solar system is of special interest
its stellar day equals
58.65 earth days
which is two-thirds of the mercurian
year
this makes the planet to face the sun
alternately first with one side then the
other in the perihelium
these regions are exposed to solar
radiation most and are referred to as
hot meridians
one of such regions boasts the largest
geological formation of mercury
designated on maps as caloris planitia
this name which is translated as a
heated plane
is fully justified as the temperatures
here reach 700 kelvin or
427 degrees celsius
making this area the hottest place on
the planet
the plane is a gigantic impact crater
measuring
1550 kilometers and accounting for about
two percent of mercury's total area
estimates show the crater to have formed
approximately 3.9 billion years ago
after a collision of the planet with a
large asteroid measuring as much as 100
meters in diameter mercury was a young
and hot protoplanet at the time
the impact would have destroyed a great
portion of crust that had barely
solidified and molten lava would have
spilt over a vast area of the planet's
surface
when it cooled and solidified the plane
was bound by a rocky crust looking like
a bright light spot easily noticeable
against dark valleys surrounding it
the surface of coloris planitia is
pockmarked with a great number of
craters measuring up to 100 kilometers
in diameter
however the most outstanding feature on
this plane is pantheon fossae
unique in the solar system this
structure is formed by a radial set of
230 troughs or extension forts with a
width from one to eight kilometers
most of the troughs do not measure over
175 kilometers in length with others
running much further than that
there is a comparatively large crater
apollodorus
lying not far from pantheon fossi's
central point
but it is still not clear whether it has
anything to do with the troughs
today there are several hypotheses as to
pantheon for size formation
according to one the giant cracks
appeared due to tectonic activity while
another deems the planet's cooling as
the reason caloris planitia is an area
of flames and light
however moving slightly to the north we
will find a land of ice
and darkness the tilt of mercury's
proper motion axis is very small which
is why its polar regions are perpetually
enveloped in dusk
the sun here either hangs by the very
horizon or does not appear in the sky at
all
its rays haven't touched the bottoms of
some of the craters for as long as
millions of years
there is no wonder that borealis
plunicia a plane surrounding the
planet's north pole is the coldest
region here the temperature in some of
its areas is around 80 kelvin which is
193 degrees celsius below zero some
deposits of water ice have been detected
here in the shade of the mountain ridges
around craters
measuring up to two meters in thickness
they are covered by a layer of rocky
dust preventing the ice from evaporation
at the same time some elevations which
do catch sun rays may get as hot as 380
kelvin or 107 degrees celsius
interestingly such contrasting areas of
the surface may lie almost next to each
other but the planet's rarefied
atmosphere does not allow them to
effectively exchange heat and so the
stark temperature contrast remains
our tour is getting us to more southern
latitudes
practically on one parallel with caloris
planitia but three and a half thousand
kilometers to the west there is one of
the largest craters on mercury
rachmaninoff
its diameter measures up to 290
kilometers and it's roughly one billion
years old there is a tall peak ring in
its center it is formed by tall mountain
peaks and measures roughly 130
kilometers in diameter the rocks in this
area are different from the rest of the
landscape there already hue and signs of
solidified streams can be distinguished
on the surface
this structure is assumed to be a
volcanic origin and is a mark of one of
the last volcanic activity events on the
planet
also the lowest point on mercury's
relief has been registered here which is
minus
5380 meters relative to the average
value for the planet
beyond the central ring there are
comparatively smooth and dark expanses
moving on to the south we will see a
gigantic escarpment stretching for 820
kilometers from southwest to northeast
it is called enterprise rupees which in
some places towers as high as several
thousand meters
there are quite a few escarpments on
mercury
but enterprise rupees is the largest
these bizarre features of terrain are
believed to have formed as the planet
could
when mercury's interior gave away some
of its heat the celestial body slightly
shrank losing roughly one percent in
volume this deformed the planet's
lithosphere which produced gigantic
foams
almost half of enterprise rupees is
located on the territory of mercury's
largest crater named rembrandt
its diameter measures 716 kilometers
and the wide basin contains a great
number of smaller features of relief
for example there are small mountain
ridges running from the crater's outer
ring to its center
their width lies within 1 and 10
kilometers and their length may reach
180 kilometers
another ridge forms a ring roughly 450
kilometers in diameter there is also an
elaborate pattern of deep cracks to be
seen on the crater's bottom which
resembles a spiderweb
it is believed that more detailed
studies of the rocks forming the
crater's surface should help us better
understand mercury's inner makeup and
the processes running in its interior
in spite of close attention paid to
mercury by astronomers
and in spite of the advancement of
observation equipment the planet is
still mysterious and largely
understudied however even mercury cannot
stay unexplored forever even at this
moment the baby colombo spacecraft is on
its way rapidly approaching this
celestial body it is a joint project of
the esa and japan the equipment on board
the spacecraft will help collect data on
the planet's surface and atmosphere
composition study the magnetosphere and
solar wind and update information on the
relief features
bepi colombo has passed mercury before
but there are still a few elaborate
maneuvers to perform up ahead to break
speed and enter operational orbit around
the planet
it is estimated that this will have
happened by 2025
after which the spacecraft will go on to
collect and transmit data
unfortunately it is going to take a
while before any probes land on
mercury's forbidding surface
the extreme conditions and challenges of
accessibility make this planet
exceptionally hard to explore
nevertheless with time it is bound to
yield its secrets to us in spite of
everything exploration of the universe
continues and we are happy to be
observing this process along with you
feel free to acknowledge our efforts
with likes and subscribe to our channel
to learn more about space
and
let's keep in touch
[Music]
[Music]
you